avete presente lo zaino di famiglia
dell'anno scorso non serve più a niente
perché quest'anno c'è lo zaino nuovo
zaino di fa vj premi lo prima che vada
esaurito prendete non sa perché ce ne
sono un sacco di copiano però stanno
esaurendo tutte quindi selene prendete
adesso poi non c'avete ma se sono
stancato a faccia con e prendetelo
zanettovich e che figo e c'ero anch'io
il suo amico magari sono le doti del
mattino ma bonsoir lo stesso e stavo a
chi su mi sposto un attimo così editing
professionista
siamo su 100 floors eravamo rimasti al
ventesimo piano let's go continua guarda
una pubblicità per sbloccare all'extra
tower tua madre vai avanti tu a maglie
devi andare avanti perché ho appena
iniziato il video non far partire la
pubblicità vanno già vista cento floors
signori let's go ti ammazzo il cugino te
lo giuro su quello che vuoi later tua
madre fammi partire morgan ha inteso 19
19 l'avevo fatto no l'avevo fatto ti
ammazzo lavoro fatto
l'avevo fatto ci ho messo anche sei anni
non me lo far rifare rifacciamolo gesù
diamo anni siamo arrivati qui non
mollerò mango buca quindi proviamoci
dover fare qui a devos cambiare le cose
in modo che la palla cada mi sembra
abbastanza easing allora io sono
abbastanza esperti in queste cose perché
quando si tratta di schiacciare i tasti
a caso in genere
me la cavo quindi aspetto che preparo le
armi l'uno seguite l'ex talking o e che
ci stavo provando da due ore quindi
scusatemi avuto un attimo di defaillance
che le donne o che percio abbiamo messi
e di là ci sta chi è che il gioco che
non solo di calcio gialla messi giallo
dove che non si come che non si parla di
ronaldo era la salsa burgio avete rotto
tutti bene me lo dico basta
sto giocando sto giocando sto giocando
no raina sta giocando zitti che dove
concentrare solo combattere con le
richieste di amicizia nel mentre che
gioco va bene combattiamo questi sono i
calzettoni questo era bracci della
fascia da capitano quale sulle scarpe
quindi le scarpe qui maiali noi
calzettoni poi c'è la maglia e poi ce la
facciano sono vedo schiacciare qualcosa
che non vedono
ecco perfette visto dopo schiacciare
richieste di amicizia o basta sempre di
calcio sì ma che è e di cosa diventa
dalla serie a sta cosa c'è da sono anche
su ma basta c'è da solo anche se c'è da
sono anche su un telefono mi fate
calciare a questo punto dovrò mandare
italia questa è sempre la risposta
all'italiano signori dove lo schiacciare
qualcosa ma non capisco
va bene frattempo vediamo potevo
schiacciare in ordine e quanta 5a cioè
un gioco del genere una volta non mi
ricordo dove ma diciamo proprio fisico
devo fare questo più togliere richieste
d'amicizia
basta dai basta che palle ma quanto dura
star o avava basta ma poi non riesco ad
andare su neanche morire che un casino
produtori mischiare tutto perché non
riusciva ad invertire quei due numeri
come faccio da vi prego che tragedia
della morte come faccio quattro ok 56 87
tua madre
l'air già come funziona questo schifo
come 12.587 scambiate lì cosa me ne
fotte che si chiami scoperto bx mi mise
aperto da minchia serve bixby sui
samsung cosa serve questo tasto a
prenderla nel culo come si mettono
insieme questi sono il 7 el 8 che non
vanno bene o sono quelli del gas sono in
organico di sotto e così sovrano
va bene si scambiano di nuovo ri
scambiamo non ho capito
vabbè next next vorrei ragazzi siamo
arrivati
ma perché perché è tutto centra tutto
col calcio perché si sono drogati di di
fifa e quelli che l'autore visto gioca
una certa di bala no stavo scherzando
icardi icardi e ha segnato ben andiamo
avanti
dovevo sentirmi un attimo pronto con me
stesso un'altra di calcio
questo non è calcio spie di aiuto di me
spiega mi che ne so cosa facile cos'è
sta roba a ci sono e ci sono due porte
niente sono fissati col calcio va bene
dopo colorare con le porte lì se vuoi
dalla mia vita dell'esatta me cosa vuoi
ai aspetta come ha fatto un capo di
qualcosa che manca manca lina questa poi
cosa che manca la linea del centrocampo
queste anche a ecco cav h
meno male che ogni tanto qualche partita
non la guardo non li e non la voglio la
pubblicità non mi interessa to khan è
stupido
vai avanti la finiamo come le cose di
calcio per cortesia abbiamo verde giallo
rosso blù mag ok c'entrano i colori per
terra giustamente però
[Musica]
lo sapevo lo sapevo che schiacciando a
casa qualcosa varie aziende
lo sapevo anche nei primi 100 ci sono
sati potrò quattro livelli che
schiacciando a caso l'avevo superato ma
è sempre più si sta giocando quando non
sei ha sede a caso come nelle verifiche
come nelle veri quale ma dobbiamo andare
al 20 ventottesimo no quindi 28 21 ben
21 va bene ancora suo cane ma basta
stock angoli un ora in poi
sei stato adottato da già fatta perfetto
inclinare il telefono easy che bello
questo livello sarà facile con rubare le
caramelle un bambino è per questo che
siete iscritti
l'idea verità non si apre ok ciao
se mi fai prendere un altro infarto ti
denuncio te lo giuro jingle bells do
sentire con l'audio con l'audio si no
grazie lo sapevo
[Applauso]
ne ne ne ne il natale fa schifo 32esimo
si è passati dal calcio a babbo natale
ovviamente perché non avevo dubbi
barry krisma a sua madre mary stage dove
per i nomi giusti
allora quella sin si chiama cometa e
quella destra si chiamerà bomber che
cosa minchia ne so delle renne di babbo
natale spiega mi regali miei grazie sono
alberi anno devo fare l'albero è ma devi
aprire però se non ha senso
perfetto
a prime da questa bibbia fammi vedere di
cosa si tratta visto che adesso appena
fatto un albero di natale o un pupazzo
di neve neve ritira dei dati un po
grossisti far uscire uno ecco intimato
di non ho capito niente
ok non ho capito niente io db livelli
non capisco niente basta che arriviamo
al quarantesimo definisce l'episodio il
posso farmi una tisana allora acqua
ok come devo fare qualche regalo perché
siamo presi bene col natale no sì ma io
non sono brava fa sta roba c'è i pacchi
devono avere un senso ok ma vai vai
veloce no come era sbagliato no ma sei
scemo ma annunciava io non sono capace
di segnare c'è un problema di fondo e
film o mensile a ed era giusto
ok perfetto ci mancava guarda che mi
facesse fare solo gli alberi di natale
ci avevo sto st paura qua però va bene
così 36 mio dio
cos'è sta roba faccia triste e faccio
felice ma io so cosa tristi bus metrò ce
n'è una sola chiave all'altra l'acqua
perfetta ed gaucan tre livelli regala
posso fare cos'è sta roba dio mio start
è ok questa truffare qua devo fare il
tutto la verità in che senso
perché devo toccare i 93
ma va a cagare non c'entra niente
labirinto la per distrarmi
devo toccare le volte in cui c'erano i
soliti sui pulsanti a fan lo sapevo che
era una cagata due livelli alla fine rea
pulsante non fa niente lo puoi smin
chiare sa che schifo
come faccio a sviluppare un pezzo perché
questo è l'ultimo che manca mai si
storto proprio capito o addio
se ora ti all'ultimo quarantesimo
signori per oggi ho dato la mia non è 39
non sommando con tasker sull 30 mesi
però il 40 lo fanno poi e non lo faccio
adesso quindi l'ultimo per oggi se gesù
ha voglia di terminavano 360 che il
numero di telefono quello che non
capisco cosa devo fare qua come molto
altro in arrivo a parte gli scherzi a
parte la cagata che non ho questo lo
voglio rifare perché non ho capito
niente
cosa ho fatto siamo cliccato qui prima
esse restano ci riuscirò mai più e non è
lecito riusciva a far molto alte in
arrivo ma e scusami ma li c'erano altri
livelli sto gioco in teoria adesso non
ce ne sono meglio è proprio arrivato al
quarantesimo
sono fiero della mia vita tantissimo
ragazzi miei spero che vi sia piaciuto è
stato atroce ogni volta che mi devo
spremere le meningi
come potete vedere i miei capelli ne
risentono ne siamo certi ragazzi uno
stesso virgilio detto mi piace ancora di
sovranità descrizione da ragazzi
[Musica]